[Music]
i'm an idiot
it's showtime
i don't deserve these powers if i'm
being honest like what am i even
contributing
wow there's already a superhero with a
red suit with a lightning bolt on it
aquaman is literally huge and he's so
manly and batman is so cool and i'm
just me
[Music]
i feel like a fraud
it doesn't matter um anyway the wizard
gave me super powers
and then everybody got super powers was
everyone going
to fight crime
okay
now everyone's kind of like doing their
own thing and i'm the only one trying to
keep it together
you understand i'm a pediatrician
right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
look i might not have as much experience
as you because i'm not super old like
you but i've seen all of the fast and
furious movies lady it's all about
family
family guys that was a signal
introducing the star of our show
his name is
[Music]
you think i know how to fix this dude
but i really don't
can be worthy
let's give it a chance
now go fight for your family go fight
for the world
[Music]
i just threw a truck and a dragon i love
my life
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good friends we have and good friends
we've lost
along the way
in this great future
you can't forget your past
society
[Applause]
is
[Applause]
[Applause]
i am queen of the most powerful nation
in the world
and my entire family
is gone
have i not given everything
and when i wake up
[Music]
here's the thing we're a team of thieves
and when you do this
you're bound to make enemies
sometimes those enemies come looking for
revenge
truth be
told we helped the wrong person steal
the wrong thing
we didn't mean to unleash the greatest
evil the world has ever known
but we're gonna fix it
so how do we pull that off
uh
figure it out over a drink probably best
you need food give us a fighting chance
we're gonna need strength you got this
right i know you don't
we also need courage
magic
and you
what is that again it's vowel there
[Music]
be warned
there is evil here
i'm glad he's on our side
this one's dangerous
but whatever happens
we'll be ready
is it exactly that you bring to this i'm
a planner i make plans you've already
made plans so if the existing plan fails
i make a new plan so you make plans that
fail no he also plays the loot not
relevant
have you given any thought
to where this ends
the table will never stop
you know this
no one
not even you
can kill everyone
you ready john
[Music]
the dream
it was clearer than a memory
and i heard the sound of her thundering
hooves
splintering shields and ringing swords
and i placed my hair up on the iron
throne
[Music]
and all the dragons roared as one
i consider the matter urgent that of
your succession
the iron throne is the most dangerous
seat in the realm
and our line is vulnerable too easily
ended
who else would have a claim
the firstborn child renera
no queen has ever sat the iron front the
king has an heir damon targaryen
i will not be made to choose between my
brother and my daughter
[Music]
knives will come out
[Music]
you are the king
your first duty is to pick a new wife
i have decided to name a new heir i'm
your hair
is a foot
do you think the realm will ever accept
me as that queen
the lords of the realm bent the knee
a woman would not inherit the iron
throne
because that is the order of things
when i'm queen i will create a new
your order has dragons
there are power men should never have
trifled with
targaryens are closer to gods than to
men
if rhaenyra comes into power she can cut
off any challenge to her succession
i am to inherit the iron's room
she will block my way
[Music]
if you never imagined yourself
on the iron throne
where he sacrificed
[Music]
wow jesus what the hell man killing
control no overwhelming feelings of rage
no a normal amount of rage you do revert
back to gen 4 when you sleep was the air
horn really necessary for comedy
absolutely
this is a multi-year journey you're
about to embark on
yeah who's your best friend nikki
spandex
is your best friend
being a hulk asks for balance
you have so much more to learn
so i'm clearly nailing it at all these
things
if you want to go back to life as a
lawyer i i respect that
he doesn't mean that
more and more eccentric superhumans are
coming out of the woodwork
we are going to launch a division for
them and i want the she-hulk to be the
jennifer wallace
namaste
i have a serious conflict of interest
this man tried to kill my cousin bruce
yeah that's quite all right oh
people only care because i'm
representing emil bonski i think they
care cause they're like hey that girl's
green
jen do your thing i really like this
outfit
i'm not proud of this
miss walters we answer to a higher power
our universe is on the edge of a
precipice
i am a lawyer
we do things by the
the book of the shanty no the book of
american
uh loss
whether you like it or not you're now a
superhero let's do this
you know that friend you had in high
school
who was way cooler than you were
attractive got all the attention from
everyone
hello
i think i'm jealous is that what i'm
feeling
[Music]
my powers
are not a gift
but a curse
is born out of rage
[Music]
you believe you are not worthy
but you have two paths
you can be the destroyer of this world
or you can be its savior
the world needed a hero
[Applause]
instead it got me
[Music]
we thought the war
at last
was ended
today
our days of peace
begin
we thought our joys would be unending
we thought our light
would never dim
the skies
are strange
[Music]
you just hear galatians
the moment we see it
[Music]
evil does not sleep
it wins
beyond the darkness kept in shadow
to bury us all beneath the mountain
[Music]
he has no one name but many
on
if the evil rising is left unchecked
it will take us off
find the light and the shadow will not
find you
[Music]
together we can survive this
fight with me
each of us
must decide who we shall be
[Applause]
there can be no trust between hammer and
rock
eventually one or the other
must surely break
you have been told many lies of middle
earth
[Music]
[Music]
i am
[Applause]
[Music]
i am
[Music]
you want
retribution
against
him
his friends
everyone he loves
set me free
and we'll play a new game
a game of chaos
and pain
hey
allison
she's alive
she's back
[Music]
you